Hey guys!
Today is another unboxing video here on
the DLM model lifestyle and the sponsors
are the classy company called Zorrrata! So we got some jewelry today. We got some
watches, we got some bracelets, we got...
Well let me just show you what we got
Alright here we are we got four boxes
over here so let's check out the first one
Wow, that's pretty nice! Zorrata! Wow that's pretty nice Zorrata. So we got one small box and
one big one. Wow! Let's see the first one
Oh, it's a ring. It's got a lion on it.
So cool! Let me just take my wedding ring
off here. Oh yes this is quite classy and
nice
Next up let's have a look:
Wow cool these are two bangles we got
two silver bangles oh let's put it on
let's have a look
oh yes looks classy
Nice these are gonna go really well with
my clothes. They look really
sophisticated as well and that's why I
love it
The ring and these two bracelets so far
looks really awesome
Zorrata, thank you guys so much for
sending this out to me. Awesome!
Let's check out the next one, the black
one
All right these boxes all look the same
They're the same size
It looks like that
All right the first one is a bangle, it
looks really good, looks classy
Let's put it on. Oh yeah it looks pretty
neat very very nice very classy
Well done guys!
The next one let's check it
out
Another one it's pretty nice but
look it looks a little bit different
here
well let's put it on
yeah pretty nice
All right!
This is so much fun, let's try the next one
Let's have a look
Oooh... Wow...
This is an anchor wow. So cool
So cool! I love this anchor bracelet I love fishing I
love the water. So this is... I'm gonna wear
this a lot. All right here we go and next
one let's check it out
This is the last
one from these four boxes so let's have
a look
oh, it's another anchor bracelet. I just
said I loved it right and now there's
another one and this one is brown. This
one is pretty cool
Alright now I think
the only ones left
are the watches so
let's have a look:
Alright here's the two
watches. Now so far I am really impressed
by the boxing, it just looks very very
classy well-done Zorrata. All of the
boxes look very classy. Now let's
check out the watches
Alright so it comes with some of the
instructions and care of what you have
to do let's check it out
nice very nice very nice let's open it
ooh that is what you see first. It's so
cool! This packaging is amazing. Look at
that. Wow so this is the sapphire watch
the Academy white crock as you can see
there. Let's take it off.
Check it out:
It actually fits pretty well with the
outfit that I have on but this is a
really nice watch my goodness
Alright let's try the next one
Wow this is really nice
It says here it's got genuine Italian
leather which is really awesome as well.
On the other side, it says Zorrata over
here. Pretty stylish. Man, I like it!
let's try it on here we go it's pretty
awesome right? It's very similar to the
other one. The only difference is this
one got a black croc there in the middle
but both of them are really really
stylish they look classy and I'm gonna
probably heard them a lot
If you want to check them out, I have added the links for you in the video description
so you can check it out. If you liked
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
and we'll go talk soon Cheers